something really interesting happened in
court yesterday that his potential
far-reaching implications for the movie
industry so there are a couple of people
who are suing Universal Studios over the
movie yesterday specifically the fact
that actress Anna De armas appeared in
trailers but not in the final film they
sued for that being deceptive marketing
now Universal tried to get the case
dismissed arguing that first of all this
happened semi-regularly things get lost
in the edit and if you let it go forward
it sets the standard where an audience
member could theoretically sue a studio
simply because the idea of what they
thought the movie would be based on the
trailer didn't match the reality now the
judge rejected those saying that first
of all for someone to try and move
forward with a claim it has to be an
assumption that would be reasonable for
most people to make so you can't just
Sue because well I thought it'd be
better but also that his ruling was
fairly narrowly focused on you literally
showed someone in a trailer who is
literally not there that is potentially
deceptive because an actor is a reason
why people might go and see a movie and
this has the potential to mean that
trailers might be made much closer to
release so that these studios are sure
they have a finished film and this
doesn't happen